electricity where's it come from well in
San Francisco we built out some charging
stations you can go to our garages
you're going to be going a lot more
places in the next few years we want to
build out tens of thousands of charging
stations throughout our city i want you
to ultimately go to a parking meter and
rather than just paying more for your
parking meter you may get a little more
in this case and that is you can plug in
to that parking meter we're going to be
rolling out twenty-five percent of all
our parking meters in San Francisco
we're moving away from those ugly poles
and we're getting rid of them and we're
going to have boxes and we're going to
be the first city with congestion
pricing strategies for parking and new
technology where you actually have
sensors underneath the parking space and
when the car is there you'll know on
your PDA or your home computer on a
car's not there you'll know that space
is available and you'll actually be able
to check it ahead of time and we'll
price it based upon strategy of
congestion so be more expensive to park
during peak time much less expensive
during off-peak time in order to
encourage that our peak opportunity to
spend more and to level out that demand
model twenty-five percent and we're
starting this year it's called SF part
but we want to incorporate a strategy as
well so you can plug in to some of these
parking meters the good thing from San
Francisco is all our municipal energy is
completely green and renewable comes
from a chechi